Can I bring a fair moderator?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Can I bring a fair moderator?
>> Okay. So why why am I not fair? Why?
>> So then don't force me. You don't have
when it's time for cross examination.
You don't ask question. You answer
questions. I said no question. God
logic. I said no question for him. God
logic. Let him do the question then you
will answer the
>> Joe brother. No this is not how this
goes.
>> Jesus never Jesus never said allow me to
land. No hold on you. have to allow me
to land my place. He's cutting me off
while I'm answering post.
>> Don't let people put your questions
without you.
>> No, no, no. I'm because what Jesus says
there, did you tell the people to take
yourself and your mother as gods besides
me? Let me finish. Let me finish.
>> Okay. So, uh it's okay. The time is up.
So, uh
>> so I can't I can't finish my answer.
>> Let's respect the time. You you go the
best man. Here's my question. Here's my
question on top of that. Stop
interrupting me. Here's my question.
Stop interrupting me. This is my
question. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Uh, God,
you said that you
said after question in chapter 3:55,
allow me to finish my question. Notice
how he's interrupting me and you're not
stopping.
>> Stop him from interrupting me, host.
>> You going You going to talk?
>> Talk talk. Host, are you going to stop
him?
>> Okay. Um, he's not talking, so I say
continue.
>> Step up, be a host, be unbiased, and
check him for interrupting me, please.
>> Um, sorry. So, so, uh, when it was your
time, like when he he was
cross-examining you, I didn't interrupt
like that, right? That's why I I keep
note and
>> you did you came off and said, "Hey,
logic, don't interrupt him."
>> I'm answering you.
>> I'll ask you.
>> Can you keep quiet? Let me answer you.
I'm not done. Let me answer you. Why?
When you when you when you when you post
the question, please allow him to
answer. [clears throat]
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Don't say nothing to
me. Of course, you're going to bias.
I'm not biased. Everybody tell
>> All right. Um UTI, what does being a
helper of Allah mean? When Jesus says be
my helpers of Allah, what does that
mean?
>> To be his helper means to help him
spread the message. And the message was
given to people, let me land. Let me
land. The message was given to Jesus and
the message was not given to the
disciples and not what what others wrote
after Jesus.
>> Thank you. I appreciate it. So you just
conceded being a helper of Allah is
spreading Allah's message. Very good.
After saying that you were in here's my
question and not your message. Here's my
question on top of that. Stop
interrupting me. Here's my question.
Stop interrupting me. This is my
question. Sorry. Sorry. Uh you said that
you commented. You said after after
question
you don't have to speak again because we
are going to speak. That's what you
said. Right.
>> It's okay. We can have a biased
moderator.
>> Did you say that the debate? So are you
talking to you or what? What's going on?
>> Your time has been paused. Boss, your
time has been paused.
>> So R2, are you and me talking? I said if
he's going to comment, then you have to
allow me to comment. However, when he
was so-called building his question, he
wasn't just simply he was making points.
He wasn't building a question. He was
making points. What I was doing was
saying, "Okay, so since you conceded
that uh being a helper of Allah is
spreading the message then and that was
going to be I was I was building up to
my question. I wasn't making a separate
point."
>> No, you separate. You commented. You
commented. So I want I also want to
comment on it. You commented. So I also
want to comment on it. Can you mute him?
You commented. I also want to comment
him please cuz I'm talking.
>> You commented. Can you mute yourself
too? Mute who?
>> It's okay. So,
>> so in the middle of that, that's how hey
ladies and gentlemen, that's how you
build up a question not make different
points since you conceded that being
helper of Allah is spreading the message
of Allah. When the disciples said we
will be helpers of Allah, does that mean
that they will also be spreading the
message of Allah? Yes or no, please.
>> So, not I will not answer yes or no.
I'll answer you.
>> Of course, you won't.
>> Uhhuh. Thank you. So when the disciples
said they will be the helpers of Allah
then they were they will be those who
will carry the message which Allah has
given Jesus to go and preach not what
they themselves have written. So since
you conceded that the me that the
apostles were spreading the message,
excuse me, since you just conceded that
being a helper of Allah is spreading the
message of Allah and that the disciples
spread the message of Jesus, will there
be any time where the followers of Jesus
fail to spread the message and
disbelievers would overcome them? Yes or
no?
So this uh in Quran number 3:52-55
isn't talking about them dominating in
this world in this world rather they
will dominate in the year after
>> where does it say that the disciples in
chapter 61:14 and 355 where yes where
does it say that they will be dominant
over the disbelievers in the hereafter
not in this world where does it say that
>> okay I did listen I did not say that
they will not be dominant in this world
listen to me carefully What I said was
that what I said you see if when you
begin to make mockeries like this when I
talking I'll mock you and you cannot
talk. So [clears throat] what I said
what I said in the test what I said was
that the message will be preserved until
the coming of Muhammad. That means that
that message has been superior
>> then they the disciples will also will
also be be exonerated
>> before Allah in the hereafter. So let's
read Quran 355 then I read. No, I know.
I don't need I don't need you to read a
verse on my turn.
>> No, but you said I should read.
>> No, I didn't. No, I did not. I never
asked you to read a verse. You answered
my question. Thank you. I'm moving on to
the next question.
>> You asked me which verse. So, when you
ask which verse, it is and you and you
didn't say that. Okay. So,
>> no, you ask me. I just answered. So,
just to be clear and I answer.
>> All right. Show me. Okay. Where in verse
in chapter 3:55 does it say, "Allow me
to finish my question." Notice how he's
interrupting me. You're not stopping.
Stop him from interrupting me, host. So
you said that according to the
>> When you interrupt me, you said notice
he's doing it again. Notice he's doing
it again. What you going to do?
You going you going to
>> talk talk.
>> Host, are you going to stop him?
>> You're muted.
>> Okay. Um, he's not talking, so I say
continue.
>> This is a simple yes or no. Do not give
me a monologue. Did you not just say Did
you not just say yes or no? Did you not
just say that according to these verses,
this means that the message of Jesus
will be preserved until Muhammad's time?
Is that what you said? Yes or no? Okay.
So, that means that did the message of
Jesus get corrupted at any point in time
from the from the time of the disciples
in between Muhammad's time in between
that 600year gap. Did the message of
Jesus get corrupted at any point in
time? Yes or no?
>> Not message of Jesus. The message Allah
gave Jesus. Thank you. So, you got the
question wrong. The message Allah gave
Jesus was not corrupted and said it is
from Allah. 2793.
>> So did it get corrupted or not?
>> 5:15. Thank you.
>> Did it get corrupted or not?
>> I just answered you. I said the message
which Allah gave Jesus was preserved.
Nobody touch it. But it did notify the
fact that people wrote things. The
message.
>> Stop interrupting me. Thank you so much.
So message of Jesus. Notice host. You're
going to have to stop this guy, man.
He's interrupting me at every turn and
you're sitting there silent like a deer
in headlights. Step up, be a host, be
unbiased, and check him for interrupting
me, please.
>> Um, sorry. So, so, uh, when it was your
time, like when he he was
cross-examining you, I didn't interrupt
like that, right? That's why I I take
note and
>> you did. You came off and said, "Hey,
logic, don't interrupt him." All right.
So, you're Yeah, it's all good, guys.
We're going to win a debate against two
against a bias to and a and a and a
Muslim debater. It's all good. According
to what you just said, the message of
Jesus is unccorrupted.
However, the things that other people
wrote and attributed themselves that
they own that they made up, those are
corruptions. But the message of Jesus is
uncorrupted. Where do we get the message
of Jesus that the followers that his
followers were going around preaching?
>> Firstly, I let me correct you again and
answer you. I did not say that the
message of Jesus. I said the message
Allah gave Jesus. It's in Quran 19:30
Quran 3.
>> Can you answer my question please? Let
me I am answering you. I'm answering.
>> You haven't even touched my question.
Answer my question.
>> I'm answering you. I'm trying.
>> Can you keep quiet? Let me answer you.
I'm not done. Let me answer you.
>> When you when you when you when you post
that question, please allow him to
answer.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Don't say nothing to
me. I I got to moderate myself.
>> Let me answer you. I am answering you.
>> Here's the question again. What I did
not say
the message of the apostles that they
preached that they got from Jesus. Where
do we go to see what they preached?
That's the question. Don't waste time
doing anything else.
>> No, no, you don't tell me how to answer
you. Like I said, I never said over here
that the message of Jesus. I said the
message Allah gave Jesus and it is in
Quran 3:3 and also Quran uh chapter
number 5 and and the rest of the verses.
Now, where do we find this messages
today? It is in the Quran. Allah Allah
Allah said Allah said in Quran 5 and
also in Quran 3 and the other Quran
verses that the Quran has come with the
truth. The message was there. They hide
it
of which Allah has refused my time. You
were hiding. Notice how he's not let me
land. Let me land. Let me when you were
answering you see he can never he cannot
he cannot quite listen to my question.
Do you even know what my question was?
>> Listen to my answer. Listen to my
answer. Don't cry. Listen to my answer.
Don't cry. Listen to my answer. Don't
cry. Hold on. Hold on. By God, you uh
when when he was cross-examining you,
you said
>> something else to me. I'm done with this
debate. I'm done with this debate.
>> I said like I want to say no. Matter of
fact, you can run. Let me run.
>> How about this? Instead of this, I I I
propose that I bring my own moderator up
here cuz you're you're you're clearly
biased. I can't do that.
>> You bring your own moderator.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. No,
this is not biased. When you were when
he was cross-examining,
>> I I don't I don't want to hear anything
from you at this point. All I want is
either I bring up my own moderator or
we're done with this.
>> Can I bring a fair moderator?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Okay. So, why why am I not fair? Why?
Give me Tell me the reason why I'm not
>> I'll tell you I'll tell you why. And how
you're doing a horrible job in showing
your bias. You're not correcting him
when he's constantly interrupting me.
You are only when he's interrupting me,
you're telling me to stop. When he's not
answering my question and wasting my
time, you don't have the excuse me, you
don't have you don't have the the the
discernment to see when somebody is
pontificating or wasting time. Instead,
you allow them to waffle and waste my
time. You did not allow you did not
allow me to comment, but he was able to
make all types of comments on his turn.
So, with you being a sad I'm willing to
Yeah. I'm willing to continue if you
allow me to bring up a moderator.
>> Hold on. Hold on. If the audience will
be very fair when it it was he was
cross-examining you. You were reading
you were reading
Actu 9 and Act 22 from from your your
your laptop. Did you complain about it?
>> Why why did I read that?
>> You you were didn't you read Act chapter
9. The question was why? Why did I read
that?
>> Yes. Yes. Because it because you wanted
to answer him, right?
>> No. Why did I read it? Notice you're the
moderator. You're not paying attention.
What happened? What caused me to read
the verses? Was it of my own self or did
he ask me to read it?
>> You asked you you asked a question. You
asked a question and he was reading and
you said and you said something that now
he was reading and he and I was the one
to to read from your side, right? He
>> he asked me to read the verses. That's
the only reason why I read the verses.
>> No, he he read it and you were saying
something and he asked me to make I'm
going tell you right now, bro. If you if
you if you're going to be the only
moderator here, this debate is over.
This is not fair.
>> I hope I debate is over. This is
embarrassing. 1.1 1.1k people here, they
they can witness that. Yeah, I knew you
would be like this, but man, you're
terrible. This is I'm biased. Terrible.
I'm not biased. I'm not biased.
>> All right. So, can I bring up
[clears throat] Can I Can I bring So, to
So, cuz I want to finish the debate. Can
I bring up Let me answer.
>> Can I Can I bring up Let me answer you.
Let's go.
Let me answer.
>> Why? Why should you bring up a
co-odderator? When when I was
moderating, did you bring when I was
asking question? You do bring Did you
bring co-odderator? Do not allow any.
Can I bring up?
Of course, you can go.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Are you telling me?
Are you telling me that I'm biased? So I
>> I already said I already said that. I'm
asking can I bring can I bring you
cannot bring
to you notice how you got him
interrupting me still to this day you
see how I'm trying to talk to you and
you still are letting him out you are
complaining if you can say nothing to
him look at you [laughter] got your
tongue panicking got your tongue you
can't say nothing to this guy
>> so I'm I'm ask again I'm I'm ask it
again I'm saying it to you can I bring
can I bring can I bring like a baby bro
you keep complaining like a You keep
dying like a baby. You are matured, bro.
>> You hold on. Hold on.
>> You ask the question, I'm answering you
allow.
>> He don't even respect this.
>> Look at him. Do you respect him? Do you
respect him? Do you respect him?
>> Hold on. Hold on.
>> Do you respect? You even insulted him.
You said he doesn't have [laughter]
insulted him.
>> You're right. I have no respect for him.
Neither do I have respect for you, bro.
>> Hold on. Uh uh um go logic logic
>> be uh me I don't want to be biased here.
Okay, that's why I said when even even
if you are going to watch the if you are
going to watch the video back, I want I
wanted to I wanted to come in because
when you were answering the the
question, you can take one you can you
can take two minutes to answer one